Yeah.
Okay.
So you're,
you're weaving a number
of things together.
So the first is your discovery
that if you look at the data,
that things are getting better at a rate
that's so remarkable that it is really
nothing short of miraculous.
And you've produced dozens of graphs
showing that in enlightenment.
Now,
I noticed the same thing about three years
ago when I was working for a UN panel
on economic sustainability.
The writ for the,
for the secretary general,
the original narrative was extremely
pessimistic and detailed how we were
destroying the planet and how everything
was getting works and how we were at,
uh,
at each other's throats.
And I started to read extremely widely
and I found that on measure after measure
with some notable exceptions
like ocean oceanic overfishing,
we have been doing so staggeringly much
better in the last hundred and 50 years
that you can't believe it on almost every,
on almost every measure you can imagine,
which is exactly what you detail
out and enlightenment now.
And,
and then now that that's a secret,
let's say people don't know about it.
And Yeah,
and that's strange.
And then you also associated
with a critique of the,
of,
of the enlightenment and
scientific rationality.
And it seems to me that you're implying,
or perhaps you're stating explicitly that
you're,
you're stating explicitly that there's
a connection between the pessimism and
the lack of knowledge about this and
the critique of the enlightenment and
rationality.
Because there's a question here.
If things are getting so much better
and if the news is overwhelming on that
front,
I mean,
some of the things you
outlined are like the weather,
the decrease decreases in starvation
I suppose are the most remarkable.
And the provision of bountiful
food on less and less far bunt,
which is not something that people don't.
It's like,
if all this is happening,
why don't we know about it?
And how is it linked to the,
how do you think if,
if it all is linked to the critique of,
of enlightenment rationality,
what are the reasons?
Is,
uh,
an interaction between the nature of
journalism and the nature of cognition?
They,
we,
uh,
the news is about what happens,
not what hasn't happened.
And a lot of the,
uh,
very beneficial developments
consist of things that don't happen.
Countries that are at peace,
that used to be
kids who are not starving.
Um,
a kit,
uh,
terrorist attacks that do not happen.
You never see a journalist saying,
I'm reporting live from a country
that's been at peace for 40 years.
But if a war breaks out,
you can be sure that we'll
hear about it all the more.
So now that to a majority
of humanity consists of,
uh,
on the spot video.
Journalists thanks to smart phones,
uh,
also,
bad things can happen quickly.
Things can blow up,
worst can start,
a massacre can happen,
but good things aren't built in a day.
And they often consist of incremental
improvements with few percentage points a
year that the compound
that that accumulate.
But that can never make the news because
they never happened all of a sudden on
a Thursday in October.
But together with all the,
the,
um,
cognitive impediments to
understanding the state of the world,
the fact that news
reports memorable events.
And we know,
uh,
from the,
study of the cognition of risk and
probability from Daniel Kahneman and Amos
Tversky,
that we tend to assess probability
and risk by a shortcut called the
availability heuristic.
Namely,
the easier it is to I dredge
up an example from memory,
the more likely we think something is.
And so people think that a
tornadoes kill a lot of people,
but they don't realize that falling
off ladders kills far more people.
I just,
cause when someone falls off a ladder,
it doesn't make the news.
But when there is a tornado it does.
Yeah.
Do you know that solar power kills more
people to nuclear power every a year?
I did not know that,
but it doesn't surprise me because
nuclear power kills no one,
I suppose as installers fall off,
roof installers fall off roofs.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
Well,
so,
so that's interesting.
So you can imagine that.
So good news or bad news,
his son is dramatic.
We're,
we're tilted towards the processing
of negative information in any case.
Well,
that's right.
We don't naturally computer ratio between,
uh,
occurrences and not occurrences,
which is of course what
goes into a probability and
rational assessment of risk
and probability.
So there's that,
but it's,
it's more than that than that
because in intellectual life,
in large parts of academia and in,
uh,
among commentators and pundits,
there is an ideology of,
uh,
of decline.
It goes back to the 19th century,
uh,
part of the counter
enlightenment that arose in a,
as a reaction to enlightenment,
hopes for,
for progress and
rationality that said that,
that,
that the holes that society is Western
civilization is teetering on the brink or
it's circling,
circling the drain and
it's going to collapse,
uh,
any,
any time now.
And it's up to the intellectuals
and commentators and,
uh,
to,
point out how decadent to degenerate
society is and to people like that musical
progress comes also in a front
there.
The reaction is,
hey,
we've been,
we've been a warning,
all of you about how society
is on the verge of collapse.
Don't come around and tell us
that if everything's going fine,
we're,
what are we going to do now?
Yeah.
You identify a lot of that with
the romantic types like Russo.
And when I was reading,
I wondered to the,
there's a,
there's a powerful Marxists narrative
that's run it's course for about 130 years
too.
That's predicated on the idea that
there's an oppressed class and the no
pressure class.
And that narrative seems also to thrive
on or two to be a fronted by the idea
that the current,
the current system might be
producing benefits across the board.
I think you do in fact,
in one part of the book ask about
whether or not these benefits are only
accruing,
for example,
to the rich.
And that doesn't seem to
be the case as far as,
as far as the data indicates.
Is that a fair,
quite the contrary.
The most dramatic
improvements have been at the,
at the bottom among re,
uh,
extreme poor where,
the proportion of the world's
population living in extreme poverty,
it's fallen over the last couple of
centuries from probably around 90% to less
than 10%.
And the United Nations is,
sends one of it's millennium elegant
goals to eliminate extreme poverty
everywhere by the year 2030.
That's probably too optimistic at
the fact that it can be set as a,
uh,
as a,
as a plausible aspiration.
Is it self astonishing?
Oh,
I know the UN had said as
one of its millennial goals,
the having of absolute poverty between
2000 and 2015 and that was accomplished
by 2012
exactly.
Ahead of schedule.
Yes,
exactly.
And that
Marxism has a,
a,
a complicated relationship to progress
because Marxist doctrine actually does,
uh,
layout up pathway to progress.
Unfortunately,
that pathway consists of
violet class conflict.
I,
it isn't the enlightenment
ideal of progress through,
uh,
through problem solving,
the pro se,
uh,
belief that a nature throws problems at
us and that if we applied brain power,
we can gradually chip away at them.
Mentally of progress is quite different.
And you're right that there is a,
a pretty strong,
there are critiques of progress both
from the left and from the right,
but from,
from the left,
uh,
there is a,
um,
uh,
kind of contempt for institutions like,
like markets like liberal democracy
that deserve a lot of the credit for the
progress that we've made
in that would be to,
uh,
at least in the academic left a,
an despising of the very idea of progress.
And I found that that the,
the only political faction is actually
sympathetic to progress or libertarians
that have been a number of
rational optimist books,
uh,
in the last decade by people like Matt
Ridley and Ron Bailey and Johan Norberg
that,
uh,
that do have an overlapping vision to
the one that I took on the light light
down and we documenting progress.
Um,
but both from the,
the,
uh,
academic left and from
the political right,
there has been a,
uh,
a contempt for the notion of progress
or their different reasons in academia.
It goes back to the Romantics too.
So as you mentioned,
but also to Schopenhauer nature.
Heidegger,
the existentialists,
the critical theorists
of the Frankfurt school,
large swaths of the academic humanities.
Uh,
actually the test,
the enlightenment,
I ironically enough,
not by no means all of them,
but I have to have,
but there's a significant faction
questionnaire,
kitchen partners.
Why,
I mean one of the things that really
struck me as I've gone through this
material over the last years is
that this is really good news.
Particularly it doesn't really matter
whether you're on the left to the right.
If you're on the left,
you think that the fact that the poorest
of the poor are being lifted out of
their abject,
absolute abject misery
at a rate that's just,
I don't think you could hope for a faster
improvement no matter how optimistic
you work.
And then on the right of course,
the fact that the benefits
of liberal democracy,
let's say,
and free markets are
driving this in large part,
you'd take would also be
a cause for celebration.